welcome back to another edition of The
Gadget Lab podcast on Michael chlorine
I'm Mike Isaac so the big news this week
was adobe announced end of life for
flash player that runs in mobile web
browsers that is correct that is
basically vindicating everything that
Steve Jobs has kind of said about flash
and flash problems on mobile well it's
not only Steve Jobs proponents of web
standards everywhere you know that there
are better things to do on mobile
devices then suck their battery and
processing power by forcing them to run
flash player namely html5 right right
that's the set of technologies that
we're moving to that we've been moving
to for a few years and now looks like
it's finally going to happen by default
is yeah well it was funny the news broke
on Tuesday night i believe so it leaked
out that adobe sent an email to a lot of
their developer community who is which
is largely composed of sort of
evangelical flash proponents right there
the flash needs to be everywhere it's
kind of a holdover i believe from the
days of when flash kind of saved
everything from the browser Wars you
know you kind of know yeah flash flood
has always kind of been a stopgap you
know everybody wants video in the
browser and there's no intelligent way
to do video in the browser so here's
this technology that will get it done
for now and then it just ended up
sticking around forever and you know
because there are so many different
screens and so many different problems
getting it to work across multiple
platforms it was just sort of ended up
being buggy at all the ends yeah and so
enter html5 right and this sort of thing
that can tie everything together right
the sort of open set of standards versus
the proprietary you know flash and this
is sort of the future writer this is
where it's the future present I think
more than anything because you know
there are html5 versions of multimedia
sites out there ready as you know if you
if you go on now your your iPhone or
your Android phone
flash player turned off you could find
all kinds of video on the web that play
in the browser but you also find a lot
that just doesn't work games and ads and
a lot of video just doesn't work so it
still needs a lot of work and that this
I mean this is a far-off sort of thing
but now it's now it's like Adobe it's up
to them to shift their resources rather
than selling flash kits to people or
flash tools they can start selling hdmi
html5 toolkit right yeah convert the
tools that I publisher put put what they
have created onto the web in a way that
does not for mobiles that does not use
flash player right um and you know it's
also it's I think the big vindication
part of it is that for a very long time
Adobe kept saying don't worry we're
working on it we're helping we're doing
the best we can to improve performance
the flash player on mobiles and that was
their script for like three years and
then yeah every time we talked to them
too it was it was just like you you know
if i came across problems like with the
playbook when we had the playbook it was
totally screwing up on me and I came
across problems and like it's not our
problem it's not us it's not us I mean
this is sort of like them passively
admitting defeat right yeah yeah finally
you know instead of saying instead of
saying roaring run out for identify
homies exactly anyway instead of saying
for years and years that don't worry to
be awesome any day well now it's it's
it's gonna be more awesome now that it's
gone already so we're still a long way
to go on video gallon mobiles fam and
you probably already know that because
you're frustrated every day we video out
in your mobile I'm sure like we are all
right yeah but something about mobile
got a little bit less frustrating this
week ah iOS 5 right so when when the
update finally rolled out to you know
iOS devices everyone was sort of excited
and you know who a new version and then
they found that their battery life was
being sucked out at a quite a bit faster
rate than the night used to write
smartphones obviously a battery life
issues
but it was just getting sacked like that
so Apple had released a press release
last week saying that they were going to
address the issue some bugs in the
initial rollout of the operating system
we should see it in a few weeks and now
they actually released some early
versions to people i believe on monday
of this week earlier this week and then
they just sent a wide release out on
thursday so if you install it or you you
don't have no iPhone yeah you know Gotye
listen yeah I haven't even installed it
yet but people are reporting that it
does solve the problem yeah I think
Christina Bonnington had spoken with a
few of the early test case people and
she was saying that there's a marked
difference already in the rollout okay
so good at least you have fun at work do
you remember when Apple had that problem
with the antenna and people were
complaining that they weren't getting
enough bars so Apple adjusted the
display oh now I told you to hold your
hand well I'm talking about it's a
separate issues how are you doing with
enough it was the issue with what they
weren't seeing enough bars and like all
of a sudden you know it looks like I
don't have any bars so they adjusted the
height of the bars to make it easier to
see do you think that's what they did
where they just adjust over their
battery do now have this many more
pixels battery power and they just made
a wire is ingenious actually if that's
probably a lot easier than rolling out
of 10 yeah so if you're watching this at
Apple the typology should totally do um
well of course Apple's not the only
smartphone out there that's awesome
another one so we like the sound effect
hello moto this is Motorola's latest
sort of product it's so you remember the
old the old ass razor you had in high
school in my case high school I think I
don't know I still have one used to do
remember the reason there's a user on
your desk outside right there yes this
flip phone the razor flip phone the slim
and awesome flip phone the best seller
right right that Motorola sort of bought
their way back into actually being a
competitor in the cell phone space to
write that came out and it was like the
thinnest smartphone at the time and
everyone went crazy for it and so this
is the successor to the original RAZR
called the droid razr which looks
absolutely nothing like the first one
it's more of a branding thing I think
except for the fact that it is very thin
it's a somewhere around a quarter of an
inch thick and its pretty long it's
pretty it's like a four point four point
five inch screens with it I think it
fits 4.3 inches 4.3 anyway it's a big
screen it's pretty thin and it's got
sort of some of these crude remnants
that are not necessarily required like
it has a Kevlar back right am literally
what they make bulletproof vests out of
but so in but you can't like shoot I
don't think I don't think we can get
shot at the phone no it's like when they
used to carry the Bible in their pocket
right but this is this is actually it's
a great phone for klutzes we found out
because we're both klutzes but it has a
steel chassis inside of it and the
Kevlar back and the girl of grass on the
front yeah and the housing is is
especially thick around the edges so it
does actually stand up to abuse yeah you
can sit on it in your back pocket and it
won't like snap in half even though it
is pretty good I mean granted most
smartphones are pretty rugged you know
then they won't shatter or crack when
you drop them but this one seeing as how
thin it is it's nice to see that the
that Motorola's taken the extra care to
make it that much more idiot proof right
and that the fortunately so they have
the samsung is coming out with the
Galaxy Nexus right the next generation
android phone with ice cream sandwich so
it's kind of like weird timing for
motorola come out with their flagship
phone and then this next you know
four-point-oh version but this is going
to be upgradable to ice cream sandwich
so people learn to worry about their
phone immediately being outdated as soon
as they buy it well that having been
said this is a dual-core felony we've
got quad core phones now yeah so if i go
out by one of these am I gonna be
kicking myself in February because now
there's a quad-core motorola yeah i mean
the other thing you have to think about
those battery life like how fast is a
quad-core good i mean where people are
already complaining about dual core
phone sucking down battery life how fast
is a quad core you're gonna have like 20
minutes of game playing and then you
gotta go charger your phone I don't know
well I don't know and do you even need
that much power do you need four cores
and you're on point and I'm doing these
like Ablett in a tablet games in a phone
no I mean for what I use my phone for
you know if it increases my camera
shutter speed from point seven seconds
2.6 seconds then you know I'm not going
to you know run around with my hair on
fire screaming about how it's the
greatest thing ever um I probably would
I even notice right and I and I don't
think I mean that's for maybe the
nitty-gritty detail oriented people but
like if for the normal for the normal
folk out there they're not gonna have
been i canna care that much so you can
find Mike Isaac's full review of the
motorola droid razr hot new sexiness on
wired com product reviews very very soon
yeah as soon as he files okay i'm going
to crack the whip on me yeah i have to
write it and then and then you'll be
able to read it and we will see you next
time with some exciting more more
exciting gadget news not more exciting
gadgets than this because what could
possibly be more exciting this but a
greater quantity of
new and exciting gadgets to show you
how's that until next time